>>> MORE BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT
AFTER AUTHOR SALMAN RUSHDIE WAS
ATTACKED AT AN EVENT IN NEW YORK
TODAY.
ACCORDING TO NEW YORK TIME
INTERVIEW WITH HIS AGENT,
RUSHDIE IS CURRENTLY ON A
VENTILATOR AND WILL LIKELY LOSE
AN EYE.
HE ALSO SUFFERED DAMAGE TO HIS
ARM AND LIVER.
HE WAS STABBED AT LEAST TWICE
TODAY BEFORE GIVING A LECTURE IN
WESTERN NEW YORK.
AUTHORITIES HAVE IDENTIFIED THE
SUSPECT AS A 24-YEAR-OLD FROM
NEW JERSEY.
SHIMON PROKUPECZ TONIGHT HAS
DETAILS.
>> Reporter: FAMED AUTHOR SALMAN
RUSHDIE WAS SCHEDULED TO SPEAK
AT A LECTURE SERIES WHEN
WITNESSES SAY A MAN JUMPED ONTO
THE STAGE JUST AS THE EVENT WAS
GETTING UNDERWAY AND BEGAN
PUNCHING AND STABBING RUSHDIE.
ONE WITNESS TOLD CNN SHE COUNTED
7 TO 10 STABBING MOTIONS BEFORE
FLEEING TO HER OWN SAFETY.
RUSHDIE SUFFERED STABS TO THE
NECK AND ABDOMEN AND WAS AIR
LIFTED TO AN AREA HOSPITAL.
>> IT WAS A STATE POLICE OFFICER
WHO STOOD UP AND SAVED HIS LIFE,
PROTECTED HIM, AS WELL AS THE
MODERATOR WHO WAS ATTACKED AS
WELL.
>> Reporter: THE SUSPECT WAS
QUICKLY TAKEN INTO CUSTODY.
NEW YORK STATE POLICE IDENTIFIED
HIM AS 24-YEAR-OLD HADI MATAR.
>> THERE WAS A LOT OF MAYHEM AND
CRYING, PEOPLE RUSHING FROM THE
AUDIENCE UP ON THE STAGE.
>> THE 75-YEAR-OLD AUTHOR WAS
BORN IN MUMBAI AND LATER MOVED
TO THE UK.
RUSHDIE IS ACCUSTOMED TO LIVING
UNDER THREAT.
HIS CONTROVERSIAL FOURTH NOVEL,
"THE SATANIC VERSES" PUBLISHED
IN 1988, SPARKED PUBLIC
DEMONSTRATIONS AROUND THE WORLD.
IN 1989, THE LATE IRANIAN LEADER
ISSUED A RELIGIOUS DECREE ON
RUSHDIE CALLING FOR HIS DEATH.
RUSHDIE LIVED UNDER BRITISH
PROTECTION FOR NEARLY TEN YEARS
BEFORE THE IRANIAN GOVERNMENT
ANNOUNCED IT WOULD NO LONGER
ENFORCE THE FAK WAH.
RUSHDIE WROTE A MEMOIR ABOUT
THAT ERA OF HIS LIFE.
THE NAME HE USED WHILE IN
HIDING.
HE HAS BEEN OUTSPOKEN OVER THE
YEARS ABOUT LIVING THROUGH THAT
TIME.
>> THE BEST WAY THAT I CAN --
WHAT I CAN DO TO FIGHT THIS IS
TO SHOW THAT, YOU KNOW, IN THE
WAY THAT A CHILD SHOWS A BULLY
IN THE PLAYGROUND, I AIN'T
SCARED OF YOU.
AND THE BEST THING I CAN DO IS
TO GO ON BEING THE BEST WRITER I
CAN BE AND TO LEAD AS OPEN A
PROFESSIONAL AND PERSONAL LIFE
AS I CAN.
AND THAT IS JUST A WAY OF SAYING
THAT THERE MAY BE THIS DANGER
AND IT'S A TERRIBLE THING AND
IT'S AN UGLY THING AND WE NEED
TO FIGHT IT AND WE NEED TO
DEFEAT IT.
BUT WE DON'T NEED TO HIDE UNDER
THE BED.
>> ANDERSON, THE FBI HAS NOW
JOINED THIS INVESTIGATION.
THEY'RE WORKING WITH LOCAL
POLICE AND THE STATE POLICE HERE
IN NEW YORK REALLY TRYING TO
SORT OUT IF THIS WAS PART OF
SOME BIGGER PLOT TO ASSASSINATE
HIM.
IT'S REALLY CONCERNING.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A REALLY, REALLY
BRUTAL ATTACK, BRAZEN IN THE WAY
IT WAS DONE.
SO, CERTAINLY HAS AUTHORITIES
ALL OVER -- REALLY ALL OVER THE
WORLD RIGHT NOW CONCERNED AS TO
WHAT WAS REALLY BEHIND HERE.
WE STILL HAVE A LOT TO LEARN.
THE SUSPECT LEFT BEHIND A
BACKPACK.
AUTHORITIES ARE WAITING FOR A
SEARCH WARRANT TO GET SOME OF
THOSE CONTENTS OUT AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT'S IN THERE.
WE'VE AL